so the first question is is there a
reason why you do what you do what
inspired you to do this today well you
know the reason why I did it is well you
know as the story goes I started doing
it from my cousins and it was neat for
me even at the time in back in 2005 when
I started I had a day job but was neat
to you know be able to do something that
could help my cousin in a tangible and
at first I started tutoring her live but
then I started recording the lectures
once I had a bunch of cousins that I was
tutoring and I wanted a way to scale up
and it was it was it was kind of
exciting for me back in two thousand six
when I made the first videos I start
tutoring my cousin 2004 but in 2006 when
I made the first videos it was exciting
this idea that I could make this content
that it would be able to reach my
cousins and teach them now and they'll
always have it around to review and it
could also teach the next generation of
cousins or the next generation of kids
it could teach my future kids I didn't
have kids at the time I have kids now
and so a big motivating factor is that
at minimum it could just help the people
that I care about and if I put it into
the public domain and and and maybe it
could help the broader people of a
community of human beings I guess is the
one way to think about it and I guess on
some degree that happened I put them out
there with the intent of at minimum
helping just a few people but a lot of
people just started to notice it word of
mouth and it began to spread and it and
then the more that that happened I
started getting feedback from people
saying that it really helped them help
them pass exams help them get into
colleges or pursue a certain career and
that just became hugely fulfilling more
fulfilling than anything else that I've
ever done in any in any role and so it
was a little bit of a addictive to keep
making more videos and by 2009 it became
so interesting that I decided to quit my
day job and do it and do it full time
and we got funding last year in 2010 and
it's just been a a wild and positive
ride ever since then so it's a I think
that makes it pretty obvious what
inspired me I guess number to your
online education beats the adage of no
free lunch how do you provide so much in
education in all for free well I guess
there's a two-part question is 11 is the
rationale what is the rationale for
making it free and two is how do we
provide it and how can we afford to
continue to provide it for
free the the first you know why should
it be free is what when I set out to
make this content actually what made it
fun for me when I set out to make this
content there wasn't a profit motive
that it was genuinely just to help my
cousins and the few people who notices
on youtube and we had thought about it
at different points in time creating a
profit model around it but any profit
model you put around it or any revenue
model who put around it means
restricting access to it and it bothered
me I mean it took the fun out of what we
were doing it took the potential and and
and the impact of what we were doing and
so you know the the principle here is is
if we can make content that scales in
multiple ways and it can reach many many
people if the incremental delivery cost
for that extra person is close to zero
and if that thing can continue to teach
forever and and and as if you believe as
I believe that education really should
be a fundamental human right we would
feel a little dirty charging for that
content that we really feel the need to
to make to put it out there and have as
many people as possible accesses and
that really what drives me and what
drives the rest of our team as for how
do we think we can keep it free you know
there's multiple ways one we do accept
donations on our site and people are
donating and we're hoping that that can
support us up to some degree and also
there is a lot of you know there are a
lot of great foundations and
well-wishers who're who are hoping to
help improve global education and I
think they're starting to realize that
we are probably one of the most scalable
it's not the most scalable way of doing
it and so our expenses for producing
Khan Academy maintaining the site they
exist but they're very small relative to
the number of people we're reaching and
the impact that we can have over a
larger period of time and I think
foundations are realizing that and I
think hopefully they'll continue to
support us I as long as we continue to
deliver a good content in good software
so that's that's my hope between
foundations and and people who found
value at Khan Academy if they want to
donate it if they have the means to
donate it they can get both of those
going I think that can keep us going for
it for the foreseeable future number
three I am inspired to hear about your
life achievements
there must be some truly inspiring
factors that have pushed you to attain
multiple degrees in different fields
from renowned USA universities which
only some special individuals can
achieve what are were those an inspired
PhD candidate a deed Ryan puchong um you
know yeah I mean there must be a we're
all kind of a product of our to some
degree the product of our experiences I
would say you know my my I would say my
sister was three years old or had it had
a fairly strong influence she was always
the good student I was always the
because she was a good student and she
always went three she was always three
years ahead of her by the time I got to
a teacher's class I think they had
expectations of me and I think that's a
powerful thing when when people expect
you to be a good student and now it's
not a false expectation it's a genuine
expectation based on the fact that you
are ferry's brother and so I think that
really helped me and I think my sister
also went you know when she graduated
from high school she and this wasn't
something that was done in you know no
one really knew had gone to any fancy
universities but she made the decision
that she wanted to go to a good
university and and so she navigated the
whole thing herself got in even got the
financial aid we didn't we weren't well
off at all you know you know we frankly
my family was making below the poverty
line at the time so she figured out how
to get how to get financial aid and all
the rest and so it you know it allowed
me to see how one can actually get
opportunities for them and I think the
u.s. is pretty great that way that you
can go to schools that are at least on
face value very expensive but if you
apply and you're good student and you
have the right need they will make it so
that you can attend it you end up with
loans and all the rest but it's worth it
so I saw my sister do that it that had a
big impact it made me realize that it's
possible the other factors you know I
think I was I happen to know a few kids
who are motivated me I who I used to
look up to there was a kid ten years
older than me in New Orleans a another
Bengali kid who tajin Roy and he you
know he just he he by the time he
graduated from high school he had
already finished his undergraduate
degree as well he done it at Tulane in
New Orleans then he went and on get a
PhD he's now gotten literally two PhDs
in an MD so he's you know
quite an educated guide when you see
people like that you meet them at a
dinner party or family friends it at
least opens your mind that those type of
things are possible and i think you know
in particular why i went to MIT and it
was i remember one of my uncle's were
studying engineering and at the
university of new orleans and he this
was this was when i was very young I was
seven or eight years old and I remember
telling him that I wanted to study
engineering to and and and he doesn't
even remember doing this and I remember
him telling me well if you study
engineering you should go to MIT and
it's one of those things that just kind
of enter in your head at a very young
age and he doesn't even remember saying
it he just happened to say it on a whim
but it entered my head at a young age
and to some degree everything I did
after that was was kind of with that
goal not even clear on how to fulfill it
but in the back of my mind knowing that
I wanted to do that and I think you
can't underestimate that impact in terms
of the actual you know doing well I
think there's a lot to be said about
really when you're learning the material
especially the fundamental materials it
as you go through schooling to not just
focus on what you need to know for the
next test but to focus on really
understanding it deeply because the
people who understand it deeply who
really understand the core concepts
really deeply they end up finding more
sophisticated things as again to higher
level mathematics and science they tend
to find that intuitive and the people
who understand it superficially they
tend to find it gets harder and harder
as they go further and further in the
mathematical career so the biggest favor
I think any student can do for
themselves early on it's just to make
sure that whatever they're learning
whatever basic concepts they're learning
they understand it left right and center
and I mean understand not just be able
to compute it but actually intuitively
know what what it's representing and and
having almost a way to conceptualize and
visualize those those things number four
are you planning to open the online
material to other languages to benefit
globally this is similar to Wikipedia so
this is from Arthur Sam Kuala Lumpur yes
the simple answer is yes we are opening
the materials we're translating into 10
languages right now we're captioning it
in multiple languages that's on a
volunteer basis anyone can go and start
captioning it to their language of their
choice and and over the next few years
we are going to try to figure out ways
to get kind of more on the ground on
the ground use cases in in the
developing world so it's definitely
something high on our priority list
number five what is the most effective
methodology to educate slow learners
Tabitha CC boy Penang you know I I'll
tell you the most effective methodology
to teach anyone and and I'm not
necessarily a big fan of calling you
know in our traditional education system
there we tend to say oh those people are
slower those people are fast but I think
those are sometimes just based on
self-confidence or what gaps they
already have in their knowledge the what
I say to any learners to make sure that
they have no gaps in their knowledge
don't try to learn algebra until you've
really mastered fractions and decimals
and negative numbers and don't try to
master calculus until you've really
mastered algebra so and that's what
we're trying to do with the Khan Academy
we're trying to have this this mastery
base you don't move on until you've
mastered one concept and it goes at your
pace so if it takes you extra time to
learn something deeply that's okay you
don't have to rush it because the pace
of the classes is going on question
number six what are your favorite strong
subjects and why Bernard Gideon lim
penang you know it if if you had asked
me in high school I would have said oh
you know by far I would have said math
and physics and but if you ask me now i
would say any of the things on the Khan
Academy because my policy to myself and
I view this as a kind of a commitment to
the people who use Khan Academy is that
I won't make a video unless I find it
unless I unless I see why that subject
is interesting because if I don't see
it's interesting there's no way that I'm
going to be able to communicate that
interest to other people and so you know
I'll tell you that my favorite suffixes
are the one that I'm making videos on at
the moment and when I focus on another
subject it'll be that subject so it's
it's really really loved above I hope I
don't sound like I'm not answering the
question but I really don't have a
single favorite subject I actually find
all of them fascinating I could I mean I
I can dive into biology and find that
fast anything I love physics i love i
love art history i love history I love
any of the above so so i won't i won't
pick any favorites number seven where do
you see yourself in the next five to ten
years is there something you would like
to see achieved
by then Walter k Kate on Barack in the
next five to ten years I hope that Khan
Academy actually turns into the you know
and it's already doing this a little bit
but I hope it turns into the place where
anyone can go to to learn anything and
they feel like they go there and not
only is the information there but
there's a structure around it and
eventually and we're not doing this yet
but we want to do this there's a
community at the Khan Academy that they
can leverage to to help their own
development and you know over five to
ten years I hope there's a model where
we can start to give people the evidence
they need that they know that subject so
that we can help reduce tuition costs
because people will start to be able to
maybe test out of some subjects or place
into some subjects or get credit for
what they what they already know so we
have a lot on our plate it's hard you
know I couldn't imagine where we are now
a year ago so it's hard for me to fully
visualize five to ten years but but i
think what i'm hoping kind of kinda me
becomes over the long term is an
institution that can that can serve as
many people as possible and that is here
to stay that's not just a flash in the
pan not just a trend that people are
excited about in the near term number
eight how do you recruit your online
tutors trainers what do you look for are
you planning to expand your team Marco
suraj ahora so the first part of your
answer is as of right now I am the only
person on the site making videos so that
was pretty easy to recruit them I just
had to convince myself but to answer
your question we are looking to expand
the faculty so to speak we so probably
over the next few months expect to see
some new videos we're being very careful
though because I think are the value of
the Khan Academy is that when people go
there they know that they're going to
get something interesting that's quality
that they can trust that that is
approachable and so we don't want to
just have any content up there we want
content that really does speak to
students and so we're being very careful
who we bring on but we have a couple of
people in the pipeline that I'm pretty
but I'm pretty excited about but if you
think about your you know who I'm
looking for we're looking for people who
have deep subject mastery deep love of
the subject so they find beauty in what
they are teaching and they are
approachable they're the type of people
you want to have dinner with they are
down to earth they are not condescending
they're not arrogant
they are fun they can make fun of
themselves they have you know they're
there there may be a little bit witty
and eccentric all of the above and if we
can find people like that and they like
making videos and they can make a lot of
videos we find people like that or you
know people like that is let us know all
right number nine in your opinion what
are some of the benefits of providing
online tutoring as opposed to
conventional tutoring I'm gonna Jerome
silly young so I don't think it's an
either/or proposition but i think what
what online especially the Khan Academy
form of online tutoring words you know
videos and exercises you can do it at
your own pace at your own time you don't
have the you don't have the fear of
someone judging you you can review stuff
that you forgot you can you know
essentially masters things and progress
at your own pace with that said is there
will be some times and you know we're
going to try to reduce those times as
much as possible by making good content
but there are sometimes with the videos
and the exercises just won't cut it and
and there there's nothing better than
having a live mentor tutor who can take
you past those total points and so you
know the I the ideal is actually a bit
of both where Khan Academy can do a lot
of the first pass blocking and tackling
handle a lot of the core material and if
someone has a teacher or tutor that can
take them to the next level of depth and
or and really show an interest and
mentor them on how they progress
intellectually and then number ten how
does salman khan what how does someone
khan when he's not doing what he does
relax roslyn muhammad Petaling Jaya I
like to read books and and you might not
be surprised that I like to read science
fiction books especially the other
things I like to do maybe are a little
bit I I love playing guitar I'm not that
great at it so don't expect music videos
from me although we might see music
videos from someone else in the not too
far off future and I like I really like
being out of nature I like to you know
out here where i live in Northern
California there's actually a lot of
good places to hike and there's a lot of
redwood forests and things so I you know
when I really want to relax there's
really nothing better than going for a
nice long walk through the woods and I
think that's all the questions and let's
see number one IIIi think I didn't
to who asked the question so number one
was asked by Jeff Leon Kuala Lumpur and
number two was asked by Boober sing
seremban and then number three was a
deed ryan from puchong so I think I
asked I told everyone else number four
was asked by Arthur Sam and I think I
said all the other people who ask the
questions so thanks for the great
questions and i hope i answered them